die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen das Wichtigste vom
Sport hat Sven FOS für sie viel
Wintersport schönen guten Abend unsere
großen
Themen Zeichen gegen Rechts zetausende
demonstrieren in Deutschland gegen
Extremismus und für eine wehrhafte
Demokratie roaler Stabwechsel margrete
übergibt die Amtsgeschäfte an ihren Sohn
Frederik dänemark hat ein neu
König und Etappenziel nordmazedonien bei
der heimem hofft die DHB Auswahl auf den
vorzeitigen Einzug in die
Ko-Runde nachdem vor kurzem ein Treffen
von Neonazis unter anderem mit AFD
Politikern bekannt wurde sind jetzt
zahlreiche Menschen in mehreren Städten
Deutschlands gegen die extreme Rechte
und für die Demokratie auf die Straße
gegangen in Berlin demonstrierten heute
laut Polizei rund 15 000 Menschen in
Potzdam waren es tausende darunter
Kanzler Scholz und Außenministerin
berbur mehr dazu von Nicola Albrecht und
Stefanie
gagosch die demokratischen Rechte nutzen
um gegen Rechts ein Zeichen zu setzen es
sei eine Mischung aus Entsetzen und
Scham die sie auf die Straße getrieben
hat erzählen uns viele Menschen hier in
potzdamm und zwar nicht nur Vertreter
von Parteien sondern vor allem
Brandenburgs Bürger am schlimmsten finde
ich dass die demokratischen Leute sich
gegen soerfleischen und wissen gar nicht
mehr um was es überhaupt geht in Potzdam
müssen wir heute Flagge zeigen gegen das
was in der vergangenen Woche in unserer
Stadt passiert ist passiert ist dass
hier ein Geheimtreffen von AFD
Politikern rechtsextremen und Neonazis
stattgefunden hat die in dieser Villa
über Pläne zur Vertreibung von Millionen
Menschen beraten haben sichtlich
erschüttert davon hatte der
Oberbürgermeister potzdamms Mike
Schubert zur Demo aufgerufen
wir lassen uns unser Stadt unser Land
unsere Demokratie nicht von den neuen
Nazis stehen Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Außenministerin berbock wohnen beide in
pozdam und folgten offenbar recht
spontan dem Aufruf des
Oberbürgermeisters als solidarische
Bürger wie sie
bekundeten alle g den Faschismus nicht
mehr still sein die schweigende Mehrheit
mobilisieren dafür gingen auch tausende
Menschen in Berlin auf die Straße das
ist ein völlig neue Qualität ich hoffe
sehr dass dieser Horror von potzam in
der Nähe von von wandseeh dass der ein
großes Aufwachen in Deutschland
herbeiführt beide Demonstrationen
verliefen friedlich ohne Anfeindungen
ohne
Zwischenfälle in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
hatten die ampelparteien ein klimageld
für Bürgerin und Bürger angekündigt
Finanzminister Lindner will aber erst in
der nächsten Legislaturperiode darüber
Unentscheiden das klimageld würde ja die
Förderung die es jetzt gebe etwa für
Heizungen und Ladesäulen ersetzen man
könne das Geld nicht zweimal ausgeben
sagte Lindner der neuen osnerbrücker
Zeitung um die Zukunft der Ukraine geht
es heute in der wo regierungsvertreterin
und Vertreter aus rund 80 Ländern kommen
dort zu einem vertraulichen Treffen mit
einem Berater des ukrainischen
Präsidenten zusammen es geht um
zelenskis Friedensplan unter anderem den
Abzug aller russischen Truppen vorsieht
und die Frage wie ein diplomatischer Weg
zu einem Ende des Krieges aussehen
könnte mehr von Andreas
küast es ist der Tag bevor nach Davos
die Präsidenten die Kanzler die Minister
kommen es ist der Tag für eine
verschwiegene Runde für einen öffentlich
bisher kaum wahrgenommenen
diplomatischen
Versuch danke für ihre Gastfreundschaft
sagt andre jermack die rechte Hand von
Präsident selenski und dann zeigen sich
die anderen rechten Hände einmal kurz
der Öffentlichkeit hier stehen so viele
Präsidenten Kanzler und königsberater
wie noch nie hier steht die vierte
weltukraineekonferenz nach ihren ersten
Treffen in jidda in Kopenhagen und in
valalletta nehmen in Davos schon mehr
als 80 Staaten teil darunter die Ukraine
die USA und Brasilien Russland ist nicht
dabei das Treffen ist keine friedensver
das Treffen kann bestenfalls dazu führen
dass spätere Friedensverhandlungen
vorbereitet werden die Ukraine versucht
den Davos vor allem die Staaten aus dem
globalen Süden von ihren Forderungen
ihrer friedensformel zu überzeugen
Staaten wie Brasilien tragen die
Einschätzung Russlands vor sie lautet
diese Verhandlungen sein eine
FS es ist illusorisch zu glauben dass
Russland wenn wir es eingeladen hätten
teilnehmen würde
trotzdem könne die Verständigung auf
Grundprinzipien dazu beitragen Russland
eines Tages an den Verhandlungstisch zu
bekommen das wären dann
Friedensgespräche die ihren Namen
verdienen unter dem Titel Ernährung im
Wandel hat sich in den letzten Monaten
ein Rat aus zufällig zusammengestellten
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern aus ganz
Deutschland mit der Zukunft der
Ernährung
beschäftigt wichtigste Forderung ist ein
kostenfreies undes des Mittagessen für
alle Kinder in Schulen und
Kitas außerdem spricht sich der
Bürgerrat für eine klare Kennzeichnung
der Herkunft und Haltung auf tierischen
Lebensmitteln aus die Empfehlungen des
Rates werden nun an die entsprechenden
parlamentsgrämien
weitergegeben im Südwesten Islands ist
zum zweiten Mal innerhalb weniger Wochen
ein Vulkan ausgebrochen seit dem Morgen
sprudelt Lava aus einem Erdspalt vor der
Eruption hatte es mehrere intensive Erd
ben gegeben der nahegelegene Ort
grinderwig in dem rund 4000 Menschen
leben musste erneut evakuiert werden
mittlerweile haben sich die Lavaströme
an das Fischerdorf herangefressen
einzelne Häuser stehen in Flammen ob und
wann die Menschen nach grinderweg
zurückkehren können ist derzeit
ungewiss in Dänemark ist heute ein neuer
König ausgerufen worden Frederik der X
seine Mutter Königin margrete die Zite
hat abgedankt freiwillig zu Lebzeiten
auf den Thron zu verzichten das gab es
in unserem Nachbarland seit fast 900
Jahren nicht mehr über diesen besonderen
Tag in kppenhagen berichtet so
hatkaldi ihre Majestät Königin margretee
hat abgedankt lang lebe seine Majestät
König Frederik der
X auf diesen Moment haben sie gewartet
ausgehart bei Eiseskälte auf dem Platz
vor dem Palast tausende denänen feiern
ihren neuen König dieser zeigt sich
sichtlich bewegt verbunden verpflichtet
dem Königreich Dänemark sein
wahspruch das ist eine Verantwortung die
ich mit Respekt annehme stolz und großer
Freude ich benötige all die
Unterstützung die ich bekommen kann von
meiner geliebten Frau von meiner Familie
von euch und von dem was größer ist als
[Applaus]
Frederik erbt die dienstälteste
Monarchie der Welt ein historischer
Moment Gott bewahre den König wünscht
margrete und verlässt unter Tränen den
Saal das war ein großes Erlebnis ein
historischer Augenblick und cool die
Stimmung zu spüren er wird ein moderner
König ein zeitgemäßer König der das dem
der dafür bekannt ist informell und
bodenständig zu sein und sich in seiner
neuen Rolle dem Kampf gegen dem
Klimawandel verschrieben
hat viel Wintersport gab's an diesem
Sonntag wenn toller Folge jetzt z.B beim
Bob ja mit einem Doppelsieg beendeten
die deutschen bobpilotinnen den Weltcup
in St Mauritz Laura Nolte gewann vor
Lisa buckwitz im Zweier auch bei den
Männern waren zwei deutsche Teams vorn
Johannes Lochner auch im großen
Schlitten seinen deutschen Konkurrenten
Francesco Friedrich hinter sich bei der
heimweltmeisterschaft in Winterberg in 6
Wochen erwarten alle das Duell der
beiden
Toppiloten
schiprungweltmeisterin Katharina Schmied
hat ihren ersten Podestplatz der Saison
geholt in saporo wurde die 27-Jährige
zweite bei den Männern sprang Andreas
Wellinger in Wisler auf Platz 3 nach
Schanzenrekord mit
144/b Met gestern landete Wellinger
heute schon nach 131 bzw
128,5 m den Sieg holte sich turnesieger
Ryo
Kobayashi und das erste das Ergebnis vom
ersten Sonntagsspiel der Fußball
buundesliga Bochum und Bremen trennen
sich ein Z ein Unentschieden zweiter
Auftritt der deutschen Handballer bei
der Heim EM in gut einer Stunde geht's
los gegen nordmazedonien jorgplus in
Berlin ist das heute eine Pflichtaufgabe
ja sen eine Pflichtaufgabe dann
irgendwie schon aber ein Schaulaufen
wird es für die deutsche Mannschaft ganz
bestimmt nicht werden denn das Team aus
nordmazedonien ist dann schon ein
unangenehm zu spielender Gegner das hat
übrigens auch der sechsfache Weltmeister
aus Frankreich erleben dürfen denn da
haben die Nord das Team aus
nordmazedonien lange Zeit mitgehalten
aber das dürfte die deutsche Mannschaft
nicht schrecken das Team ist
mittlerweile hier an der Halle
angekommen und hat auch schon die eigene
Kabine gefunden und ich würde sagen es
herrscht so etwas wie na ja eine
konzentrierte Vorfreude auf das was da
heute vor der Mannschaft liegt auch
Alfred gislerson ist mittlerweile hier
der lugt schon ein bisschen bei dem
Spiel Schweiz gegen die Franzosen und na
ja ich würde sagen das was der
Bundestrainer ausgelobt hat das ist das
was wir heute sehen werden ein Sieg soll
her zwei Punkte und damit immer in die
Chance sich vorzeitig für die Hauptrunde
zu qualifizieren du hast es gesagt in
einer Stunde wird Ernst hier in Berlin
danke ge konzentrierte vor he das gilt
auch für uns ab 20:15 Uhr im ZDF Jana
absolut danke Sven schauen wir noch auf
die
Wetteraussichten es gibt viel Schnee
Schneeregen und Graupelschauer
vereinzelt Gewitter am Nordrand der
Mittelgebirge längerer Schneefall
lebhafter Westwind mit stürmischen Böhen
-2 bis +
5°. das heute journal können Sie dann in
der Halbzeitpause des em handballspieles
sehen um kurz nach 21 Uhr mit Anne
gellineck